I know so many people who had incredible
wealth and they lost it all Fame wealth
power success they're all wonderful
outcomes I don't want to diminish them
they're just terrible intentions I've
been in three major phases of My Life as
a mentor in the first I spent it with
the urban poor I worked with gangbangers
drug cartels people who were incredibly
impoverished there were internal
structures of failure in their mental
mindsets that actually held them back
then I moved to LA and started working
with artists creatives the most
intuitive people in the world I thought
they're going to be different and I
realized oh my gosh they had the same
mental structure issues that the poor
had and then I started working with
people who were from the hundred
millions to the billions and I thought
okay it's going to be different here and
it didn't take 5 minutes before I
realized oh my gosh this guy has a
billion dollars he has the exact same
mental structures as the creative and
the exact same mental structures as the
guy who's poor